for more than a year now we have been
documenting how the Democrats working in
tandem with far-left smear squads have
said about to stifle conservative speech
now these folks think of themselves as
rough-and-tumble kind of football
players but they're ultimately blinded
by the bright lights through campaigns a
foe outraged at stoked on social media
they whip up their frenzied followers
and then that justifies their trampling
on the free speech rights of others
everybody's all upset but they've never
tried their little charade on someone
like Candace Owens before she entered
their holy ground a Judiciary Committee
hearing convened by Democrats the topic
hate crimes and the rise of white
nationalism I received word on my way in
that many of the journalists were
confused as to why I was invited and
none of them knew that I myself was the
victim of a hate crime when I was in
high school
white supremacy racism nashit white
nationalism words that once held real
meaning have now become nothing more
than election strategies every four
years the black communities offered
handouts in fear handouts and fear the
ancestry of black Americans is being
insulted every single day I will not
pretend to be a victim in this country I
know that that makes many people on the
Left uncomfortable Oh
smokin well congressman ted Lieu was
lying in wait from his Owens and held up
a little micro recorder and played this
edited clip I actually don't have any
problems at all with the word
nationalism I think that it gets the
definition gets poisoned by leaders and
actually want globalism the first thing
people think about in at least in
America is Hitler but if Hitler just
wanted to make Germany great and have
things run well okay fine
problem is is that he wanted he had
dreams outside of Germany he wanted to
globalize I was her grandfather behind
her by the way now rather than ask her
questions or heck even challenge her
views on on the victimology being
peddled by liberals to black America
liberal henchmen Lew attacked
character no he doesn't honestly believe
that Candice Owens was somehow
empathizing with Hitler of course he
doesn't but guess what
Owens refused to let the moment pass
unchallenged when I responded to is that
I do not believe that we should be
characterizing Hitler as a nationalist
he was a homicidal psychopathic maniac
that killed his own people
a nationalist would not kill their own
people I think it's pretty apparent that
mr. lube believes that black people are
stupid and will not pursue the full clip
in its entirety it is not proper to
refer to spera jingly or with to a
member of the committee the witness will
not do that again
witness may continue sure even though I
was called despicable witness may not
refer to remember the committee is
stupid I didn't refer to him as dude but
that's not what I said
that's not what I said at all you didn't
listen to what I said may I continue
please can you imagine if a liberal
african-american woman were treated this
way what they'd do if she were speaking
her truth feminists across America would
be in an all-out revolt you'd have like
Samantha B would be sputtering about
misogyny Gillibrand and Warren would be
leading candlelight vigils across
America at campaign rallies now let me
be crystal clear here what's happening
is an all-out assault assault assault on
America's freedom of conscience freedom
of expression freedom of movement and
it's even happening to children who step
out of line now last night we brought
you the story of an 11 year old little
girl Bella Moscato who was called out by
her teacher in Long Island for choosing
Donald Trump as her hero for a school
report again imagine the uproar if some
teacher asked some student not to write
about Barack Obama as her or his hero
and of course media lightweights use the
same tactics think that is so disturbing
about what William Barr is doing is
here's yet another person who is
trashing their reputation in the name of
donald trump another person who my god
where has he been the past couple years
will exit the White House sorry that he
had trashed his reputation for donald
trump scarborough questioning bill bar
okay well what scarborough is implying
there is that he and his poisonous
panelists will relentlessly malign bill
bar and anyone else who works for or
even supports the administration for
that matter now his words are thinly
veiled threats they're a warning shot
across the bow
not just for bar but for anyone even
thinking of taking a job with the trump
administration former DHS secretary
Kristen Nielsen is another target
yesterday Alexandria costia Cortez
tweeted favorably in response to a
leftist who wants to punish Nielson even
as she returns to private life so
apparently it wasn't enough to harass
people at their homes or in restaurants
now far-left activists launched petition
drives to prevent these former Trump
staffers from earning a living after
their government service nice now what
these activists are saying is this the
price of working for Trump is you are
now and forever unclean an untouchable
my friends no CEO no college president
nor any potential employer should ever
bow to these types of threats and that's
what they are as threats now even once
reasonable fairly reasonable Democrats
are now supporting this campaign of
branding the Trump team with a big
scarlet letter a big T she had a
background in cybersecurity but I think
that's not what she's going to be known
for and it frankly has to raise the
question for anyone who's offered a
cabinet opportunity with President Trump
whether their reputation will survive
he's going to continue to look for
people that in many ways are willing to
violate their oath of office which is to
and for
the law and that means that he's going
to have a very difficult time finding
good people even Leon Panetta it's
unbelievable but that's the goal isn't
it the left is uninterested in actually
doing things called
solving problems it's moved to 24/7
character assassination of trumps
cabinet his staff of course Trump
himself but really anyone who supports
his policies and has the guts to say so
even little kids like that girl on Long
Island now rather than staying my
friends in a defensive Crouch when they
threaten and demonize patriotic
Americans we at the Ingraham angle will
continue to expose these tactics the
funding of these organizations
underneath all of it and their ultimate
aims and together I'm extremely
confident tonight that we're going to
preserve free and open debate and this
country that we all love and that's the
angle